(light bright music)
We are going to turn our attention to lower GI.
Nothing still to disclose.
Here are our learning objectives
and we're going to start with irritable bowel syndrome.
Remember, this is a syndrome characterized
by altered bowel habits and abdominal pain.
The pain can get worse or better with bowel movements
and there's an absence
of detectable structural abnormalities.
There are four subtypes.
You will be leaving here today
with a Bristol stool scale
so that you can report tomorrow morning back on what the,
(audiences laughing)
You're awake.
One of my patients one time told me,
"You know why I like used to watch Dr. Weismiller
'cause you're crazy like me."
Okay, you can have constipation-predominant,
diarrhea-predominant, a mixed,
or it can be unsubtyped
and it's based on the Bristol stool scale.
Now here are the Rome IV diagnostic criteria for IBS.
Average at least one day per week
in the last three months,
associated with two or more of the following.
A pain related to defecation,
associated with the change
in the frequency of the stool,
associated with the change in the form
or the consistency.
Now the pain related to defecation,
it can get worse
or can get better with the stooling.
So I've got a history.
We have to include psychosocial factors here.
If I don't have any alarm symptoms or red flags
and I meet the diagnostic criteria,
we really don't need any further workup.
If I'm considering that I do because of concern,
then laboratory tests
that may be helpful or listed there
and I might need to do an imaging
directly with colonoscopy or sigmoidoscopy.
Now if we think about this therapy,
it really is individualizing treatment.
We want symptom relief
and we want improvement in quality of life.
They can be mild
in which we're just using diet lifestyle.
It could be moderate
where I've gotta manage the stress
that add pharmacotherapy
or I can be have significant issues
in terms of decreased functioning.
Now patient symptoms are consistent
with irritable bowel,
history and physical as such.
They don't have any red flags
and those are the ones I'm thinking about.
Unintentional and unexplained weight loss,
rectal bleeding, a family history of bowel,
ovarian cancer, a change in the bowel habits
persisting more than six weeks
in a person particularly who is maturing.
Now if the patient does have any of these,
I can confirm the diagnosis
and I can proceed with treatment
and it is symptom based as I said.
Now look down there though.
If you look at improving global symptoms
with this functional disorder,
using enteric coated peppermint oil
has been shown to be globally
helpful in terms of improvement.
Now enteric-coated peppermint oil,
you're using .2 to .4 CCs
typically before each meal.
It's gotta enteric-coated
because as we learn with GERD,
just taking in peppermint oil makes your GERD worse.
Now I wanna go back to the upper GI
and we had functional GI disorders.
Remember 25% were organic, 75% were functional.
From a practice perspective,
if I diagnose you with something functional,
everybody gets started on a trial of peppermint oil.
Now if you're thinking,
where am I gonna find enteric-coated,
that's all you can find now
because this is very, very popular.
In my end of one studies,
I would say 30 to 50% of the patients
get much improvement.
I had a woman about six years ago,
she had been suffering
from some form of functional disorder
for at least 10 years.
Never tried peppermint oil.
Tried her on it,
she had a 90% improvement.
She's like, "I cannot believe you.
You like worked a miracle."
Like, oh yeah, that's what I'm good at, miracles, yeah.
That was just luck of the draw.
But if they have diarrhea,
typically we're using an antidiarrhea,
bloating and distension probiotics
or linaclotide or lubiprostone.
Now antibiotics can be used here.
It's interesting,
even though there's not a infectious cause,
rifaximin and neomycin have been shown to be helpful.
Constipation, of course, soluble fiber
is typically what we're reaching for.
And then if there's a lot of abdominal pain and discomfort,
antispasmodics, antidepressants can be helpful here.
Now in terms of that fiber issue,
what are the water soluble ones we're looking for?
Well, we're trying to get a bulk laxative.
If we're thinking about this in terms of diet,
oats, apples, pear,
we want all the skins on there, beans, legumes,
these are low fermentability.
And the way this helps is that it's secondary
to increasing the fecal size bulk, okay?
So this can be very helpful.
Bulk is retained in the colon
despite the microflora
as psyllium is poorly fermented.
So if we're using a water-soluble fiber like Citrucel,
of course that's gonna be psyllium
and this can be very helpful.
Now water insoluble,
whole wheat, whole bran, brown rice,
all that fun stuff.
It prevents constipation.
It's indigestible.
Its presence also speeds things up
and moves things along
so you can help prevent the GI blockage and constipation.
So depending on what the issue is,
you'll choose either water soluble or water insoluble.
Now FODMAPs, okay.
These may cause digestive discomfort in some patients.
So restricting them has been shown
to potentially be help to improve adults with IBS
and any other functional GI disorder.
So this is the second thing we have a discussion about
when there's a functional GI disorder
is how can I restrict my FODMAPs, okay?
They're present in anything that's gluten containing,
and therefore this may be the issue
in patients who have non-celiac gluten sensitivity.
You know, gluten-free is quite in right now.
And this may be the issue in terms of why some patients
with the non-celiac gluten sensitivity
do better when they restrict gluten.
They do not cause intestinal inflammation.
Okay, so IBS then,
self-help patient education, CBT.
Global symptoms are improved with soluble
but not insoluble fiber here.
Lubiprostone and linaclotide
are effective for constipation-predominant.
Antispasmodics can be helpful,
antidepressants helpful,
and a diarrhea agents helpful.
Okay, now psychological treatment.
Look at the number needed to treat here, four.
Hypnotherapy, CBT, and psychotherapy.
Choose the one you'd like.
Okay, but I have to treat four people
to have one benefit from just this treatment.
Here's the AGA.
For a patient with functional abdominal pain,
they meet the criteria Rome IV.
Let's say you had to do a diagnostic evaluation
with a colonoscopy and/or screening CT
or a diagnostic CT.
Unless there is a major change,
you do not repeat the study.
Okay, here's our AES question.
19-year-old presents to your office for follow-up.
She reports continued intermittent
abdominal cramping and bloating, diarrhea, fatigue,
4.5-kilo weight loss.
She was diagnosed with IBS, you think it's celiac.
Which one of the following should be used
to establish a diagnosis?
Colonoscopy; serologic testing;
do serologic testing,
and then what the heck get an endoscopy;
and serologic testing initially,
followed by a colonoscopy.
Okay, C is the correct answer.
We wanna do a screening test
followed by a diagnostic test.
This is preparing you for tomorrow morning at 8:00.
There's gonna be so much fun.
We're gonna talk about screening,
sensitivity, specificity,
positive, predictive value, negative.
I mean you will be salivating it, so exciting.
Okay, serologic testing and then an endoscopy.
Okay, so celiac disease, this is autoimmune.
If we look visually,
you will see this kind of cracked-mud appearance
to the mucosa.
And when you do a biopsy
and what we do is the proximal area of the small intestine.
The second aspect of it,
you see this blunting of the villi.
Now you want to be tested
when you're consuming a diet of gluten.
Signs and symptoms,
there's really not a typical presentation.
And on the laboratory standpoint,
you can see iron-deficiency anemia,
folate deficiency, and vitamin D deficiency.
Now how do we diagnose it?
There are several serologic tests.
If they say you have to choose two on the exam,
you want to use the IgA
anti-tissue transglutaminase antibody,
and the endomysial antibody.
If you only get one,
then the IgA is the first line for serologic testing.
You then do an assessment
if that is positive of the distal aspect
of the duodenum using an EGD,
and you will see this villas flattening.
How do we treat this?
Gluten avoidance.
Now what we don't know
is what's the threshold of gluten
And any individual can tolerate.
Meaning, well, you know today,
if you say I want to have a gluten-free meal out,
they'll ask, is this an allergy
or is this a preference?
Because an allergy, you know,
these are patients who have celiac disease.
The other is maybe I just am sensitive to gluten,
but I don't have defined celiac disease.
Now inflammatory bowel disease.
Onset here is usually young adults.
More common among Caucasians.
The spectrum is from anywhere,
from Crohn's to ulcerative colitis.
We know there's a genetic role.
We don't have an infectious agent
that's been identified.
We know that there's tissue injury,
so we assume that there must be some type
of immune role as a mediator.
And we know that there are serologic markers
that help us differentiate
between ulcerative colitis and Crohn's.
Now if I'm trying to differentiate
between inflammatory bowel disease and IBS,
I can use fecal lactoferrin
and calprotectin levels.
These are serologic markers of bowel inflammation,
which you should not be seeing
with irritable bowel syndrome.
This can be of help in differentiating the two.
Now let's take a look at ulcerative colitis first.
Remember, it's confined to the mucosa.
It starts in the rectum
and it's gonna move approximately without any skips.
The continuum of disease is quite broad.
It can be quite abrupt though in its onset.
And the serologic marker
that may be helpful here,
more suggestive of ulcerative colitis
is the perinuclear antineutrophil cytoplasmic antibody.
Now what's the differential?
Well, is it amebic dysentery?
Do I have a bacterial colitis?
Do I have Crohn's disease?
Do I have microscopic colitis?
The treatment basically is gonna be sulfasalazine.
This is the first line therapy.
It's one of the most effective agents for remission.
Now the anti-tumor necrosis factors of the biologics
is where a lot of this is moving though.
But remember, you have an increased risk of infection,
you have an increased risk for lymphoma,
and your vaccines aren't gonna work as well.
Here are the key recommendations
for practice related to ulcerative colitis.
Now with Crohn's, remember this is a full wall thickness.
Any part of the GI tract can be affected.
The terminal ileum is gonna be the most common site,
and you have skip lesions.
I had a patient not too long ago, last six months.
Wife works at my institution
and sent her husband in 50s, 50 plus age.
And ongoing issues related to gastrointestinal pain.
In the process of working him up,
he went to the emergency department.
Of course they scanned his entire GI tract
and he had all this inflammation from top to bottom.
Turned out, I did a some laboratory testing further,
he has Crohn's disease.
You know, it was just interesting though,
you know, 'cause it has kind of this bimodal distribution.
Young and then as we're maturing.
Now here, CBC, C-reactive protein,
these are very helpful.
Subsequently, what was the what I was looking for?
The presence of antibodies to E. coli
outer membrane porin,
which to which he was positive
and he had antibodies to Saccharomyces cerevisiae.
Both of these in conjunction
with what we saw on imaging
was highly suggestive of Crohn's,
and he has now had two appointments with GI
to get this under control.
The colonoscopy, skip lesions,
cobblestoning, ulcerations.
Here's the treatment.
Mild disease, typically mesalamine products
will be helpful.
Once we get down to severe disease,
all bets are off.
Even the use of the anti-tumor necrosis factors
and i.e. the biologics is controversial here.
Most of these patients, if you're not responding to this,
they're going to need surgical intervention.
Okay, here are the key recommendations
as we look at Crohn's disease.
That's for your study materials.
Okay, now this table summarizes
what we just said about the serologic markers
for IBS versus celiac disease
versus inflammatory bowel disease, okay?
So put that with your study materials as well.
Now what about the risk of colorectal cancer
with inflammatory bowel disease?
The predictors of risk.
What's the duration?
What's the extent of the disease?
Is there a family history of colorectal cancer?
And do they have a concomitant diagnosis
of primary sclerosis and cholangitis?
Now what do we do here?
All patients should undergo a colonoscopy,
a maximum of eight years after the onset of symptoms.
They'll need a biopsy.
What we don't know
is what's the optimal for surveillance.
However, typically one to two years
after the initial screening, you'll do a second one.
If after two negative examinations,
the surveillance can go to every one to three years.
You want to perform this
when they are in remission though.
When would I stop this surveillance?
Potentially 75.
However, if they've had prior adenomas polyps
or they have primary sclerosing cholangitis as well,
you may want to continue in this particular group
depending on health status.
Okay, GI infections.
What are we doing with all these?
Well, we gotta replace the fluid that's lost.
You can have a voluminous diarrhea
and sometimes we can identify the agent.
What are we looking towards
in terms of the history?
Well, what kind of work do you do?
Where have you traveled?
What have you been eating?
Is somebody else sick in the house?
Have you been on recent antibiotics?
Are you immunocompromised in some way?
If I have vomiting,
I have ingested some type of preformed toxin.
Pain, I've got distension and inflammation.
If I've got fecal blood, leukocytes, cultures. O&P,
who gets all of this done?
Only if you've had travel
or the diarrhea is chronic.
Typically lasting six weeks or more, okay?
So don't be ordering O&P on everybody.
Most of this is viral and going to be self-limited.
We orally rehydrate them.
If they can't because of vomiting,
then you'll have to go to parenteral.
And then once you've accomplished the rehydration,
you'd like to do some adjustment in the diet.
You know, if you're vomiting
and have diarrhea,
you probably don't wanna serve the child's spaghetti.
As one of my patients once told me.
I'm like, "Well, what did you try?"
"I tried spaghetti," okay?
That's not a good thing
if you got a 4-year-old throwing up.
In my experience.
Avoiding high fat, simple sugars
as opposed to complex carbohydrates
because they're more easily digested.
Now let's look at this particular question.
Which the following is the most common cause
of infectious diarrhea in children
both in developed and developing countries?
Campylobacter, rotavirus, Shigella or norovirus?
Okay, it's rotavirus.
Now, when we think about common GI infections,
the two big viruses are rotavirus and norovirus.
Amongst all comers, it's gonna be norovirus.
And then we've got this other list of both bacteria
and parasitic infections we have to consider.
Now most of this is viral, as I said.
Norovirus is the leading cause
of gastroenteritis among adults.
I learned this not an easy way.
I was speaking at a conference on a cruise ship.
And during my presentation,
this virus decided to take over.
Not good.
Now rotavirus most common cause in the US.
You get large volume diarrhea.
Fecal oral spread,
daycare centers are the problem.
Necrotizing enteritis,
biliary atresia, intussusception.
Now we immunize this.
Please, first dose,
you have to be at least six weeks old.
You cannot start it after 15 weeks.
It has to be completed by eight months, know that.
Norovirus, very abrupt onset as I learned
and prompt resolution.
So by the next night, I was able to have a margarita.
I had one during the trip.
Okay, bacterial gastroenteritis.
In any given year,
this is what flip flops
amongst number one, two, and three.
Salmonella, Campylobacter, and Shigella.
Campylobacter, most of this comes
from contaminated poultry.
Severe cramps, bloody.
Culture, most of the time
you're not gonna need antibiotics.
If you have to have one
because it's culture proven, Azithro.
No fluoroquinolones, too much resistance.
Shigella, bloody, highly contagious.
We diagnose it by culture.
Treatment: kids, Bactrim;
adults, quinolone;
no vaccine for this.
Now Salmonellosis, eggs and poultry.
And yet another reason not to have a pet reptile, geez.
Vomiting, nausea.
The nontyphoidal is what we see.
Typically anywhere from six hours
to two days after exposure,
you're gonna come down
with a rather significant pain, diarrhea,
vomiting, and nausea.
It's gonna resolve spontaneously.
Self-limited, it can cause bacteremia.
So endocarditis, osteo, mycotic aneurysms.
Non-severe, no treatment.
High risk condition
because you're at increased risk for bacteremia,
because you've got severe diarrhea.
Fever, you look sick.
Levofloxacin or another fluoroquinolone
at the equivalent dose.
The typhoid type.
This is the one that is rare in the US.
The treatment is a fluoroquinolone.
We have a vaccine for this one.
Now E. coli.
This is the one that produces the Shiga toxin.
You diagnose it with culture.
You get a very striking dysentery.
Usually there's no fever, but a lot of abdominal pain.
Here's the question they're gonna ask you about this.
They're gonna want you to check a serum creatinine
because you've got a hemolytic uremic syndrome
as a possible complication.
We heard most about this with contaminated meat.
So the pink stuff that they use for burgers,
like in school cafeterias and things,
we've had some outbreaks.
Supportive antibiotic is not indicated.
Amebiasis is caused by E. histolytica.
The treatment here is gonna be metronidazole.
You get liquid bowel movements with bloody mucus.
Giardiasis, O&P, metronidazole.
It's a profuse watery diarrhea,
mostly from contaminated water.
So the typical scenario on the exam
is you're gonna have been drinking from wells.
Okay, Pseudomembranous enterocolitis.
It can occur with any antibiotic.
Today, amoxicillin is the most offending.
C. diff. look for the toxin.
Stop the antibiotic, we treat with Vanc.
Plenty of fluids.
Look at the relapse and carrier rates, very high.
Some of these patients,
you're talking about a fecal transplant.
You wanna get people excited.
You start talking about,
oh, I'm gonna do a fecal transplant on you.
You're gonna do what, where?
Using what?
New, okay, traveler's diarrhea.
Enterotoxigenic E. coli is the most common issue.
Prophylaxis, not recommended by the CDC.
Routine prophylaxis increases your risk.
So what do you want to do?
Hand washing the hand.
The alcohol-based hand sanitizer are also effective.
It reduces your risk by about a third.
Avoiding street vendor foods.
Tap water, ice and raw foods
has not been shown to reduce the risk.
So eat what you want.
Usually self-limited.
If treatment's needed,
I'm having three or more stools in eight hours.
Severe nausea, fever, blood.
Fluoroquinolones are the drug of choice
in a single dose.
The alternative is to use Azithro.
You can use bismuth.
No Bactrim, no doxy,
Very high rates of resistance here.
Loperamide can be used as an antidiarrhea,
the antidiarrheal agent,
because this is not toxigenic.
Vibrio, okay, I've visited some place
or I've had something sent to me
where I've eaten contaminated seafood.
Vigorous rehydration.
If you prove this in terms of culture,
it's doxycycline for treatment.
Here are the key points for our diarrhea extravaganza.
Put those with your study materials.
Now diverticular disease.
Oh my gosh, oh, I have my colonoscopy, Dr. Weismiller.
I have diverticuli.
You know, like 90% of patients, very common.
Most patients will never have any problem with these.
The treatment is a high fiber diet.
You no longer have to worry about seeds and stuff.
When I was growing up, my neighbor, Mrs. Miller,
she couldn't have seeds.
I'm like, "Mom, what's wrong with Mrs. Miller?
She can't eat seeds.
She has a GI issue."
Yikes, no more.
Clinical presentation.
They have acute lower abdominal pain,
fever, tachycardia, and a tender lower abdomen,
potentially with rebound.
Look at this.
If it's only the left lower quadrant,
your likelihood ratio goes up tenfold.
Now the American College of Physicians
has all new recommendations on this.
You should use an abdominal CT
when there's diagnostic uncertainty.
Signs of perforation, bleeding, obstruction, or abscess.
Of course, those patients are gonna get admitted.
Most of these will be managed
in an outpatient setting, outpatient.
We don't see any difference
in elective surgery or recurrence.
Here's the third recommendation.
In addition to doing it outpatient without antibiotics,
no difference in related complications.
Treatment failures, seven per hundred without antibiotics,
five per 100 with antibiotics.
Quality of life, no difference.
Surgery, no difference.
Length of hospitals stay, there may be no difference.
Recurrence, nine pretend without antibiotics,
10 pretend with antibiotics.
Outpatient, no antibiotics.
Here's the ACIP clinical considerations.
It's uncomplicated, so it's just localized.
If I've got complicated,
those patients tend to get admitted.
And then select patients.
You know, immunocompetent, not medically frail,
do not require hospitalization.
Those are all the ones
that can be treated as an outpatient.
What's the predictors of progression
to complicated disease?
Longer symptoms, vomiting, systemic comorbidity,
look at the high C-reactive protein
at greater than 140.
And on abdominal CT, it's very abnormal.
I've got a pericolic extraluminal air.
I've got a fluid collection.
Longer inflamed colon segment.
Here's the companion guideline
in terms of what's the diagnostic evaluation.
Colonoscopy after an initial episode
of complicated left-sided colonic diverticulitis,
against using mesalamine to prevent recurrent,
elective surgery to prevent recurrent
after initial treatment,
whether it was uncomplicated
that it's persistent or complicated.
Now the AGA recommendations mirror this.
Antibiotics selectively colonoscopy should be performed.
Mesalamine rifaximin, probiotics,
not recommended to prevent recurrence.
Small intestine cancer, it's rare.
Adenocarcinoma or lymphoma
usually is diagnosed by imaging.
Choose your study, doesn't matter,
and it's gonna be surgical.
Large intestine cancer.
Most frequent internal neoplasm in the US.
Lifetime risk is about one in 17.
These are all almost adenocarcinoma.
They arise from polyps.
The bigger the polyp,
the greater the likelihood that it's gonna degenerate.
So early detection decreases mortality.
Now there are non-modifiable risk factors.
You know, I can't change my family
or personal history if I have inflammatory bowel disease,
if there's a personal history of hereditary polyposis.
Look at the modifiable ones.
Anybody remember those?
Smoking, weight, alcohol.
Red meat consumption over 500 grams per week.
So don't feel guilty tonight about having your filet.
It's fine.
Here's the AES question.
A 45-year-old male sees you
for a health maintenance visit.
He inquires about the options for screening.
He has not had any screening tests performed in the past
and has no personal or family history.
You explain to him that there are several alternatives,
but according to the USPSTF,
recommendations regarding the optimal screening
intervals will vary by test.
He opts for a FIT test.
You recommend he repeat this test
at which of the following intervals?
Yearly, three years,
five years, or 10 years?
Excellent.
So there are seven ways that we can screen
for colorectal cancer.
And the current recommendation
is we start screening at age 45.
Both the AGA and the USPSTF say,
in the general population,
do not worry about what test is chosen.
Just choose a test.
There's three stool based.
High sensitive fecal called blood test,
the FIT test or the FIT-DNA test.
FIT-DNA is the Cologuard.
There are four direct visualizations.
Colonoscopy, CT colonography,
flex sig or flex sig with a FIT.
Now some of you may be thinking,
why would I get a flex sig?
Well, you know,
if you live four hours from the nearest referral center,
Dr. so-and-so down the street,
she does great flex sig.
We're gonna just do the flex sig every five years.
Here's why they don't worry about the test chosen
because the number of lives saved
just based on screening is basically the same.
Basically the same.
Somewhere between 22 and 24
just based on screening.
Now, can we assess risk?
There are some risk factors.
However, all adults 45 and older
should be offered screening
even if the risk factors are absent.
Now based on risk factors,
if I have a single first degree relative
with colorectal cancer or an advanced adenoma
and they're over the age of 60 when it's diagnosed,
their recall is like the general population,
10 years if I'm choosing colonoscopy.
The single first degree relative
with CRC or an advanced adenoma
and is diagnosed at younger than 60,
they get screened at 40 or 10 years younger
than the initial or sentinel event.
Their interval would be five years.
Two first degree relatives
or an advanced adenoma diagnosed at any age.
Again, the interval of screening is five years.
The AGA and their choosing wisely.
Do not repeat colorectal cancer screening
by any method for 10 years
after a high quality colonoscopy
that does not detect neoplasia.
I had a patient about two years ago.
Brand new comes into my office.
He had had a colonoscopy, no family history, five years,
four years earlier, and he wanted a FIT test done.
I said, we don't do FIT tests.
It would be contraindicated.
Well, it was his initial visit.
He stormed out of there never to be seen again.
I got a letter from his insurance company.
They wanted me to know
why I was denying this person a FIT test
as a screening for prostate cancer.
(students laughing)
Pretty easy.
It's not indicated for prostate cancer.
Never heard from them again either.
Okay, our last question.
One week after a complete
and adequate baseline screening colonoscopy,
a 51-year-old female with no history
of previous health problems.
She comes back to get the path report.
Eight millimeter single solitary polyp.
Report confirms this was a hyperplastic polyp.
Her family history is negative for colon cancer.
When does she get a repeat?
One year, three years, five years, or 10 years.
Oh good, 10 years is the correct answer.
10 years, okay.
50% of the polyps you're gonna find are hyperplastic.
They do not degenerate.
That's why you need to have the histology report.
And actually I want that over the colonoscopy report
because it's gonna tell me the size of the polyp
that was submitted and I get the histology.
So I have what I need.
If they're adenomas or serrated,
those will have different follow ups.
If they're a low risk polyp,
i.e. adenomas or serrated,
they're only one or two
and/or less than a centimeter.
Their recall is five years typically.
If there's three or more
or they're greater than a centimeter,
the recall there is going to be three years.
Do not repeat the colonoscopy for at least five years
for patients who have one or two small ones.
Completely removed via high quality colonoscopy.
So there are our key screening recommendations
for colorectal cancer
to include with your study materials
and we are done.
Thank you very much.
(light bright music)